mo le esta gritando a quien eduardo de luca che
significa paralelo Ciavatti Ilenia
afuera en la pelota de mesa Simone y nosotros en
la mitad de los rieles y cajas del país
quien votó orjos esmus
significativo que buscar singuetta io
tengo un millon y ahora silencio subimos
después del avión también hay un anciano
nivel político y por la continuidad
aunque eso significa que somos de un grado
La relación
eh
si esta diferencia el dia que haces
yo derecho que por dios un canchito
antidemocrático Hola a los gerentes
totalmente de acuerdo con leer entonces un
victoria y logro espectacular
Annarella clásico
Eh él también y ya sí era una política
anti pandemia osea era pro virus eh
eh al extraterrestre suplica
termínalo pero lo más rápido posible
no pienses en esto durante el
selección En resumen, una política antisis
etc. Como si si si no estoy mostrando el
candidato
Demócrata, er esta noche, ¿qué estás haciendo?
una victoria y ahora no querrá decir Sí
pero luego una victoria y un espectáculo
para crear una historia que
convencionalmente pensar en lo que
espectáculo
barato Lo que compré tanto y salud
Y
ejem ilustrativo un suplemento de un
partido llamado nuevo partido
adiós al privatizador etc. el
Claro apoyo a Luna
que parlanchín es que cebo japonés
Eh victoria devolvió tu eh Eh
Soy un triunfo ya lo que tu
es decir, quiere pretender que se organicen allí
luego dirigió al Inter alearse de- dell
mismo Mmm antide democraticus el rey
la reestructuración evoluciona el movimiento sarcoma
siempre fueron si el gato tal vez
normal siempre ideas y en el campo gracias
para ti, pero lo que creo que es importante es
como si pudiera organizar y articular errores
Estaria ahi brasilia holding y ste
Capital político y representativo e
pero esto no va acompañado y no
haz bastante el portazo surge
abajo y aguanta la cuarentena Aquí pero
Logro además de los 50 aumentos del párrafo 90
del